Your character actually delves into
this wellness
well rounded woman
because you show that
you're going to therapy
and I've never seen a black
woman do that on television
because that's being vulnerable
I'm Jamaican too Jamaicans
we don't talk about our feelings.
So this is basically a miracle
because
it's like they decide
they can only have so many
brown girls in one thing
I feel like now
- Theres a limit
Theres a limit
Like now it's a little
more open
but I remember the very
first thing I ever worked on
was this indie adaptation
of a play
and it was like I remember
thinking as a child
if they cast this chocolate
woman they're going to cast me.
-Mm hmm
-and I remember thinking that
But do you not still think
that way?
I have to kind of sweep
that thought under the rug
whenever you get an audition
for something
you know someone else is attached
to it and then you say...
well she looks like me and so ok
this is going to go to someone else.
It depends because sometimes
I've been surprised
like with Twilight Zone
casting me
and Jessica Williams I
was like oh...
I’ve never seen that before.
- Right
- I've never seen that before, ever.
And especially of the same
kind of tone.
Like sometimes I'll go
in for projects
and I’m like oh I know that I'm
the black role
but I know that I'm light skin so I
know that
there's going to be darker
skinned women that come in
that would actually be
better suited for the show
but if it's like a middle
America show
I know I'm gonna get cast because I'm
as black as they can go right.
I mean that I'll take that a
step further and say
sometimes I'll get audition
material and decide to myself
that I shouldn't even go
in because I am not
the kind of blackness
that they're looking for.
We gotta stop doing that to ourselves
But I mean but you know
what that all it's so funny
when you I can pinpoint
when that started
and that was with my first
manager who had...
A black Actress who was already a movie star and another
one whose star was rising
very quickly
first conversations was about
how difficult
a time he was going
to have kind of placing me
or finding me work,
a white man.
so it was something
someone actually said to you
yes.
and I had never thought about
that before ever in my life.
You know you think about your
own identity
but I never thought about...
Me being raised in Harlem
in Manhattan in a bubble
in a very liberal school
and not having had to face those questions
but I never thought about how
Someone else
someone else was going to place
you choose my identity right.
-choose my identity.
Right?
No not at all.
I mean I was like playing
Prospero in high school
like I had the most
naive, beautifully naive
understanding...
and like in some ways and a lot
of ways it served me
because I never had a ceiling
for myself.
You know but it is definitely
like a culture shock
when you like I graduated
from school
and then I was like oh
ya'll wouldn't cast me as that?
oh I play this old man?
I think I was the opposite
I grew up in a predominantly
white neighborhood
and then I made a fast
switch to a city school
and it was a performing arts
high school in Pittsburgh
and shut up Pittsburgh and.
And then it was the opposite.
It was like a predominantly
black just eclectic group
and diverse group of kids
And in my white school I was one
of three black people.
and my brother was one
of those three as well
but we counted as half, so there
were two black people
and then there was me
and my brother
and that was from middle
school to high school
and then when I aged out
in middle school
I went to the inner city school
and it was the opposite
like black kids wouldn't
accept me or girls really
and white girls wouldn't
accept me.
so I was kind of like in
this weird in-between
and I didn't know
who I was
I didn't know what my identity was
do you feel like that transferred
into the industry?
I think it did
because originally starting
out with music for my career
I went right into R&B
because I wanted to accept
and I wanted to drench my
in black culture
and I wanted to be around
really powerful strong
black women
but then in the industry
everybody kept saying
straighten your hair don't
wear it curly don't do anything
natural and then I was going
in for auditions
and I literally wouldn't
pass the paper bag test
So it was like all of this kind
of like back and forth
that I didn't really know
who I was and I never
felt like I fit in and nobody
ever really accepted me
so I had to fight to find
myself where myself was ok
in being myself and then be
able to sell it
because people just tell
you we're telling you
you I don't know what to do
with you but just you know
you're just confusing
what I think it boils down to
to and it's so crazy is
you know we can have
a long conversation about
hair right
but I don't have the beautiful
crown of curls
that most mixed actresses are
you know people decide that oh
you're mixed actress
you're not Latina. You're not
a Hawaiian God knows
you know whatever
because we look at
people and we decide
who they are based
on their hair this is insane
And when you're young
starting in this industry
people tell you you know
who you are.
And so they probably told
you like oh you can
go in like you're not Ilfinesh
who your actual heritage
and your ethnic background is
you're probably
Native American
-you could play this or you could play that
also in 2008 or whatever
ethnically ambiguous
was
-was poppin
I mean like it didn't get me work
-I was like I'm going to
have to be Dominican
-I was like my eyes are hazel though
-I claimed back .05 percent of Cherokee
it was those hazel eyes
I was like I'm so interested
and fascinated to meet this girl
-where did she come from?
-what is she, where is she?
-I think like when I started out
I didn't go to a University for it
because I'm half
Jamaican and in my culture
you got to school to become
a doctor or a nurse or a teacher
and so I did as many
indie films as I could
because I felt like maybe
I could do all of these
indie films
and it didn't matter
whether a short film like a
student film anything
pay no pay just to get
footage showing
that I could play this and
I could play that
and I thought that I could use
that in order to
once I start going out
for official work
like SAG work
then I'll be able to use
that as a reel to get in
but you were a hard though
you were ahead of the curve
because you were creating
characters where you've just made
it for yourself and now that's
kind of like where
where we are in a place now
If we can't find...
thank God
If we can't find the placements
as ourselves
as black women then we just
we create it
so you were already doing
that before you even started so...
right but I wish that I would have
done stuff with actual quality
lighting was terrible
it's the same thing I have
a trillion shorts
and that was like far more...
-that you got paid with a sandwich
-yeah I got paid with a sandwich
but it was far more
advantageous for me
you know I mean especially
in this medium then...
I mean I enjoyed my four years
of school but those
but those shorts were like...
-that was when you had your training
you know were super
important
but I had this experience
there was one agency I met
with in 2012
and they were like looking at
my photo and they're
like looking at my reel
which was full
of like working class
you know I mean
like characters and they
were like we don't
really know what to do with you
It's often times like a lot
of the reps
that we kind of go
to are the agents
that we meet to
often times they're not black
-yeah
And so they don't
really understand us.
I remember after I did precious
there were people who really
their reps who actually thought
that I was
plucked off of the street
that I was some...
they're people who don't want to meet with me
because they thought
that I was Jamaican that I
didn't speak English
and I was like Patois
is English
in Jamaica they speak English and so
which thank you I appreciate
that you know
but it's also not
understanding our culture
and not understanding
I think especially to be
black and also to be
Caribbean to not even
understand that
and like right now
I still get that
- yeah of course
I don't have an agent right now
and so I even still get that
like
oh what is she?
what do you mean what am I?
There's a fear in it though
I think that that's
kind of the predominant
base out of everything
It's the same thing
for your story for your story
we don't know what to do
with you
I don't know this look
-fear comes from not understanding
that's exactly right
It's lack of knowledge
is just ignorance
so the more that we can educate
people through platforms
like our show and show people
the diversity in the different
shades and what it looks like
and who we are when it is not one
shade of black it really isn't
there's like other things
and other things weaved
inside of it with diversity
and personality and heritage
and everything in between